- It's 12 minutes, right?
(woman speaking afar)
Is every talk 12 minutes?
- I don't know.
- Joe Nameth, you are number 12.
For all you jet home fans at home.
(calm hip-hop music)
- Instagram, wanna jump on real quick.
Tomorrow, in Los Angeles, 7 to 9PM,
Shoe Palace, doing a
little meet-and-greet,
teaming up for my sneaker
that's coming out,
my collaboration sneaker
that's coming out in November
with K-Swiss.
So, I am teaming up with them to launch it
at Shoe Palance tomorrow.
Are we switching?
- I mean, you don't have to, but
- But I like-
- You should for tomorrow.
- I mean, they're so cool.
- This is kind of my
favorite pair that they have.
Okay, good flight this morning.
How are you, brother? Good to see you.
You well? I've got a couple of bents.
I'm fireside chatting Will.i.Am.
- [Woman] Yes.
- Will?
- Oh, shit, what up, GV?
- I'm very excited to
be fireside chatting you
in a second.
- Oh, yeah, that thing's gonna be,
(Gary laughs)
hey, don't,
don't beat me up, bro.
- I won't.
- Now, as my 12 minutes.
I've got 12 minutes.
- [Woman] Will.i.Am is also on, though.
- I'm gonna talk about-
I'm gonna be the Uber of pillows.
Great, fuckface.
Everybody's trying to
communicate something
and it's awfully hard to
penetrate if you think
you're gonna be able to
just talk in an environment
where the supply and demand of talking has
fundamentally shifted.
These are always kind
of the most interesting
moments, 4 or 5 minutes
before, 7 minutes before
the keynote.
I get into that weird zone.
Where I just wanna destroy the audience.
It's the weirdest thing,
I really get competitive
with the audience itself.
I wanna give it so much
value, that I turn it
into my competitor.
It's such an interesting insight.
Anyway, pretty interesting crowd.
A lot of leaders from a
lot of different sectors
here, at Worlds, so, 12
minutes is super short.
Sometimes it takes me
12 minutes to warm up,
as you know, D-Roc.
Youtube, you guys know.
As you guys know, usually
you guys all skip the first
12 minutes of a keynote, right?
'Cause it's the backstory,
so I gotta get right into it.
I'm ironically not a
zero-to-sixty speaker on stage.
I am in rants, I can go
right there, so this will
be a good challenge.
I'm excited about it though.
Lot of friends in the audience,
a lot of acquaintances.
So, should be an interesting talk.
See what happens.
One other thing that has
been really on my mind
when it comes to entrepreneurship
and the ones that
are winning and the ones that are losing,
and the word is "gratitude."
I am stunned by people's
ability to complain
about dumb shit.
(audience laughs)
(Gary laughs)
I wish every one of you, if I could wish
any fictional thing on
you right now, I wish
that your great-great-great-
grandparents would
come up, be alive, look
you dead in the face, and
say, "You're a fucking asshole."
(audience laughs)
But the fact, I mean,
at the most micro-level,
'cause I'm actually going macro here, but
at the most micro level
of entrepreneurship,
there was never a day and
age where you were under 30,
getting 4-million-dollar
valuations and funding
on your idea, respected
in society so much because
the technology shift,
all of the sudden, 50,
60, 70-year-olds respect
your point of view,
and yet, we find things to
complain about, even though
this is the single,
disproportionate, greatest
era ever to be under
30 to build a business.
And it's not even close.
And so we complain about
things like Facebook and
Instagram changed their algorithm.
Like, let me just save
everybody a little time,
if you meet somebody
who's complaining that
their business is in
trouble because Facebook
and Instagram changed
their algorithm, that
person fucking lost.
(audience laughs)
They're done.
The one thing I've lost
that I'm now reconnected
with over the last 12
months, that I implore
everybody here gets really
connected with is that
entrepreneurship changes
every day, the market
changes every day,
things happen every day.
Entrepreneurship sucks.
I know it's cool, but let
me tell you, entrepreneuship
is lonely as shit.
One thing we don't talk
about in this group,
us friends, we like to talk
about all the good shit,
we're not talking about
the depression, and suicide
that so many of our
friends are going through
because it's the first
time they've actually
lost because school is a rigged game.
Entrepreneurship is, you're
playing against the market.
And the market doesn't give a fuck what
your grandfather did.
And so, we need to really,
really start understanding
that the number 1 trait of a number 1 is
the ability to get punched in the mouth,
the face, the stomach,
over and over and over and
over again.
I eat shit for a living.
(audience laughter and applause)
And your ability, in
this room, if you aspire
or continue to be an
entrepreneur, your ability to
eat shit is the quickest
indicator of where you end up.
Because it moves, it changes,
and we're treating it like
this awesome lifestyle
thing, putting bullshit
fucking photos on Instagram
like it's so fucking rad.
My friends, entrepreneurship
is not Coachella.
(audience laughs)
They're like, "Oh, it'll be no problem."
- [Man] So many luxury venues-
- How you doing?
- Hey, really good.
How are you?
- Good.
- Tim?
- Yeah.
- Welcome.
- [Interviewer] Alrighty, so,
what's your favorite thing about this
summit about worlds?
- The people.
You know, I think there's
so many friends and
acquaintances that come
to this event, that
are in my social graph
that I don't get to spend
time with because
everybody's kind of busy.
The people that I deem friend
and sell as acquaintances
are the ones that I
barely seek 'cause they're
hustling as well.
So, just being able to
run into that, and then,
the other 100 people, 30
people, 17 people that
I get to run into, introduce
myself, get to know them.
So I think of it as like
the depth and the width of
worlds that a lot of events
don't provide for me, so
you know, depth being that
4th or 5th time I get to
have a conversation with
somebody that's in my circle,
but with that, you know,
so many times, and it's
already happened, I've
been here just a few hours,
and last time, gaining
context with that first
introduction, to new people
that I'll know forever,
I like that.
- You say, change your
friend group, that's
one of the most important
things you can do.
How do you get started on that?
Especially living in a place like LA.
(Gary laughs)
You know?
How do you, interact with, how do you,
what's the first step to-
- It's one of the first times I've ever
talked about it on stage
today, so I'm still
kind of developing this
thought, but I've been
giving a lot of thought
to how fortunate I am.
I think a lot of people
talk about luck and,
when you're somebody
like me, you work a lot
and things of that nature,
it's hard to accept luck,
but there's no question,
things like being able to
immigrate out of the
Soviet Union or having a
mother that is so insanely
amazing, you know,
I didn't control that, that
was given to me, and so
one of the things I've been
thinking a lot about is,
well, what happens when
you're 25, you hear one of my
clips, you're somebody
else, and you're like,
"Wait, that's true."
Like, my mom stinks, or
like, my family environment
was bad, or maybe I was,
let me go another way,
maybe I was so priviledged,
that I don't have hunger.
If you now are self-aware,
deploying new thoughts,
and you understand some truths,
what can do you about it?
The only thing that I believe in is you
can't fake environment.
- Right.
- You can't fake environment.
So, if you gather yourself
with people who are
from a certain cloth, or
have a certain hunger,
or have a certain point
of view, very quickly
that rubs off on you, and I
think what people struggle
with is, when they want to
evolve, they want to stay
tried and true to their
friends, and that's a
very difficult bridge,
of selling out, in both
directions.
I think the cliche one, is
you come from not that much,
you wanna move up, that's
the one that most people
think when they hear this,
but I'll tell you that
I'm probably giving more
advice to kids that grew up
with privilege, to go and
live in reality because
that's the only way they
can offset, and that's super
hard too.
Because breaking your patterns
if extremely difficult,
but if you're unhappy with
your situation, you've gotta
change your pattern.
Much like a diet, like
if you're not happy with
where you're at, you've
got to change your patterns
in a hardcore way.
I just believe in that in
life, and that is just not
a conversation that people
are having, it's not
a very politically correct conversation.
I think I'll be historically
correct, so I'm willing
to take the short-term push-back for the
long-term success.
(upbeat music)
You change your livelihood-
when people make
a mistake, 'cause they make
$280 being a salesperson,
they wanna start a candle
company, but then they
buy a house and have all this overhead-
- Right.
- And they fucking feed
their own thing and they
never go make the candle.
(Gary speaks over man.)
If you know you wanna do something else,
and you're good at this,
save your fucking money,
and then when you jump into the pool, go
fucking rent a shithole and give yourself
that two years to see if you can do it.
And then you live with no regret.
'Cause you can always go back.
- [Man] 'Cause you never wanna
wake up saying, "What if?"
- 'Cause you can always
go back to the thing that
you're good at, that makes you money, that
you don't love.
You can always go back to that.
There's always people
looking for salespeople.
- Absolutely.
- Got it?
Super productive day,
we'll be a nice, little
clean edit for you, D-Roc.
Nice, tight day.
Gotta work out now, gotta sneak those in,
take care of your body.
Just always a good strategy.
And a couple meetings for tonight, reload
for tomorrow, just got
done with an incredible,
I don't know if you filmed it, D-Roc,
probably did, that's how
you roll, but I saw you
bullshitting with Tyler,
so maybe you didn't,
but if you did, just got
done with an incredible
recruitment call.
We're super fucking passionate about you.
I, listen, to be very frank, I've already
won because of this phone call.
Right?
Either, you go with
us, and we dominate, or
I get to make fun of
you at the pro-bowl in
9 years not coming with us.
This being a sports thing is so funny,
it's amazing how passionate I am to
these kids are making
such funny decisions,
it's like us, and not
us, it's like, you know,
in the agency world, in
the wine world, like,
us versus the rest was
close enough that it
didn't feel devastating.
These kids are, God, I
really hope they go with us.
Anyway, nonetheless, good
day, and I hope everybody's,
we're in the dog days of summer.
This is when the separation
in the marketplace happens.
You drinkin' rose?
On the beach?
(man laughs)
Or aren't you?
Cool.
(upbeat music)